what is this glass no not at all
disgusting I don't I don't I don't know
it looks the best it tastes the worst
today we are going to be trying out Oh
file which is like different cuts of
meat are we looking forward to it no I'm
just hoping to not throw up
it's called good Dada which I believe
are kidneys I hope there are no stones
it looks exactly like mushrooms that's
actually quite nice yeah like come on
it's not that bad and I'm getting a
weird aftertaste now it's not that bad I
need mouthwash so in all fairness this
looks disgusting
oh [ __ ] is thin tired down and there is
something bony at the end I have no idea
what the word that is bone man I feel
like Hannibal Lecter right now he does
eat tongue not picturing the tongue
would help
wow you really like what you already
know it dude but I guess I don't have a
heart how could you be so heartless
actually like it and the off today
system I wanna stick this out right now
this is actually like having rubber
dipped in a goddamn masala so it's
technically boobs I never thought the
first time I'll be motivating someone
feel good I didn't think boobs at bones
why does another bone in it no that's
not a bone that's of the anal I don't
think my mom's gonna forgive me sorry
mom
Cheers like there seems to be just a
surplus of oil all over you know it goes
in your mouth and we like it's just
dissolved it was really creamy flavor to
it I don't like the texture but the
taste is pretty nice if I didn't know it
was a bit like wow that does matter not
maybe I'll become more intelligent after
this I highly doubt it but sure in a
world where testicles are served as food
is this masked balls I'm used to I'll
tell you it [ __ ] will never be the
same again
it's very soft I never thought I'd say
this but I like balls in my mouth
testicles are the top two deaf finger
just like slip right down I've never
seen a testicle but I've Charlie eaten
mine all of the story
skip the tongue go right to the balls
we've struggled really hard to get away
from our Indiana Jones in the temple of
too much pressure this doesn't happen on
a day-to-day basis I have this really
bad taste in my mouth right now I'm
surprised I haven't thrown up on you yet
it also was pretty disgusting I liked
all the difference it's the masala that
kept it going
we don't have it again depends on how
drunk I would be it's turned out to be
your less harrowing experience than I
thought it would be yeah that's true